so we saw this story and we thought who
can we consult about the price of eggs
in the first name that came to mind was
Tierra solemn a chicken Enthusiast a
long time chicken expert working
informally for this show and someone
whose life has been Vindicated by the
current news Tara thank you so much for
coming on tonight so you have been
keeping chickens
famously for years now now there is an
egg shortage you must feel like the
smartest person in America
you know I will say my heart goes out to
all the chickens that lost their lives
to this horrendous bird flu that's going
on but for like local chicken owners and
like small farms
this is great for us because now people
are turning to us wanting our eggs and
finally respecting chickens like they
deserve
well so that must feel really good
because I know you've been on the show a
number of times we've always been
grateful to have you and we've gotten a
big response every time and most has
been positive some of it has been
mocking I'm sure that you have been
mocked by your family friends and
neighbors for keeping so many chickens
for being a chicken Enthusiast they're
not making fun of you anymore are they
no they're actually coming to me and
wanting my eggs and
finally needing me for something and I'm
like oh it's about time you're welcome
and do they look small yes and do they
look at the chickens a little
differently
you know I feel like at this point yes
oh dear
so really I mean the the two themes I'm
taking away from your life are
self-sufficiency and love of animals
is that fair to say
you know yeah because finally after the
years of people making fun of my
chickens and thinking that I'm weird
that I have so many roosters and so many
hens
yes I'm now like oh Told You So chickens
are finally having their glow up and
I'm so grateful for it
no but we we should just say in the
interest of animal husbandry and
accuracy uh roosters don't lay eggs
correct
no so funny thing is my hands sleep in a
different Coop and so right now we're in
front of all my roosters so a lot of
people will probably be like oh my gosh
roosters don't lay eggs
but this is easier and if you remember
last time there's bad boy Halo from the
very very first time I was on he's uh
right there in the center he was a
little star
yeah he does his job well
can I just ask you not to get two in the
Weeds on the chicken question but how do
you keep the Roosters from killing each
other
okay so I'm a full believer in roosters
are misunderstood and if you raise them
hand raise them
hold them handle them they actually are
all very nice so my six roosters coexist
really well with my other six hens
so I think it's all the way you raise
them
that's fat I you know we I actually
consulted someone with chickens after
your last appearance
um and I we both agreed you were the
chicken Whisperer
um Tierra thank you so much for joining
us today congratulations on your
Vindication and uh good luck
thank you thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight